i'm asked all the time if dawn and i are
going to do a sweet life reboot and i go
no absolutely not if you had high hopes
for a suite life of zack and cody reboot
cole sprouse is here to tell you don't
hold your breath
you know what fine i'm out here
excuse me pardon me
making a dramatic accident not happening
the riverdale star appeared on tuesday's
episode of the drew barrymore show and
opened up about why it's a big fat
no from him when it comes to bringing
back the super popular disney show
and its spin-off the suite life on deck
which he starred in with his twin
brother dylan from 2005 to
eleven reboots are a tricky thing you
know uh
you have the the original shows when
they become successful sit within this
golden
little plate of nostalgia and
when you modernize it and go back to it
it has the potential to really
disenfranchise the original fan base so
it's a very very touchy thing
i um i'm i'm asked all the time if dawn
and i are gonna do a sweet life reboot
and i go
no absolutely not so that's a hard no
no okay fine a sweet live reboot may not
be in the works
but cole joked with et back in 2018 that
he was pitching his brother to guest
star on riverdale for a
very specific role cole yes
jelly bean update anything for me yeah
jelly bean and mom are coming in this
season
really have you been suggesting anybody
that you would like to play your little
sister dylan was a big woman
for me but
he said no i mean it was a scheduling
conflict
um no i mean honestly
whoever is going to be best for the role
is going to be best for people uh our
our cast has been so well cast and i
have full faith yeah that clearly isn't
happening either
but what about a friend's reboot oh damn
it oh
damn it don't say that damn it
no don't go back to repeating damn it oh
crap
oh crap cole and dylan played the role
of ross's son ben
in the hit 90s sitcom and when et caught
up with cole in 2019
he said he's not down for that either
i'm a purist i i think
i think friends sits in this perfect
little bubble of golden nostalgia
and i think it's i think it's dangerous
to re-enter into any of those properties
and decide like
what can we do to commodify this yeah
and modernize it so i think you know i
think it should stay the way it was
and stay beautiful and and exist the way
it was
it's that same way that people have
really enjoyed it for so many years and
i don't know i think it would also be
incredibly vain for me to be here to be
like
yeah dude i need my own spin-off man
well i guess we'll just have to enjoy
seeing cole in those reruns
but during his chat with drew he did
give fans
a fun little throwback tidbit admitting
that back in the day he had a
mad crush on his co-star jennifer
aniston
that's a good one
yeah you like that one yeah you're funny
i'm funny oh thank god
it actually made it quite difficult to
work in front of her i must admit
i was a child i would stammer a lot and
i'd forget my lines
which uh i i feel like i've maintained
my composure a bit more effectively now
but it was quite difficult when i was a
kid and i was teased a little bit by the
crew
because they saw it and i would just
forget and be looking at it
okay the whole world had a crush
you